there's a theory this is the CNBC title
there's a theory that stingy Millennials
are to blame for the sluggish economy oh
my god I am so sick of New York media
ripping on Millennials there's such an
easy target it's just so long so come on
HIPPA that's her name that wrote the
article the us personal savings rate is
rising and it's holding back the economy
says a study by Raymond James savings
rates are now higher leading to excess
supply seemingly everywhere in the
economy says analyst tabatha McCourt
wrote in a note to his clients on
Thursday he believes the rising rate is
driven by millennial saving more
following the financial crisis god
forbid we can't have that Millennials
this is the article this just drives me
the the Millennials the selfie selfie
obsessed
avvocato toast loving generation might
be behind the lower socio he can slow ur
economic growth well why don't we blame
them for global warming oh my gosh this
new generation scarred by the financial
crisis is saving more than the
free-spending boomers did before them
and it's causing an economic imbalance
personal savings rate is eight point one
percent as of August by comparison in
1996 the rate was five point seven
percent so let me get this straight your
conclusion from the millennials saving
more is that they were scarred how about
if I give you a new conclusion
oftentimes when someone is raised by
alcoholic parents they don't drink in
other words they learn the lessons of
what brought curses into their family
instead of blessings into their family
so if the Millennials were raised by
materialistic conspicuous consumption
baby boomers my generation who are
retiring broke because they've invested
and saved no money as a generation maybe
the Millennials are the smartest
generation to come along and for
generations and they actually looked at
the boomers and went well that crap
didn't work
maybe they notice what brought curses on
their family instead of blessings on
their family maybe their conservative
tendencies and their need for their
their lowered need for conspicuous
consumption and materialism is not based
on scarring maybe it's based on the fact
that they're the most spiritually mature
generation at their age to come along in
about three generations they don't need
stuff to be happy I think it's a huge
compliment to Millennials oh yeah some
of them are fraidy-cats and they're in
the corner like a snowflake sucking
their thumb I get that but I'll tell you
what I know a whole bunch of them that
are braver than a bunch of you
especially people write articles like
this stuff whole bunch of them just
aren't motivated by stuff my generation
and we we created the 80s remember the
80s I remember buy everything and if
buying everything if conspicuous
consumption and excessive materialism to
the point that there is no savings for
your future if that's how a positive
economy is created you don't know
anything about a positive economy a
positive economy has a balance between
consumption and a savings rate and 8.1%
not particularly high as a savings rate
your rate of generosity and your rate of
savings is an indication of the maturity
of your population the emotional
maturity of your population emotionally
mature people know that living for self
a hundred percent of the time is called
selfish and it's unrewarding emotionally
mature people are outlandish outlandish
ly outrageously generous emotionally
mature people have learned how to delay
pleasure it's one sign of emotional
maturity no discipline seems Pleasant at
the time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness if you can save money and
be outrageously generous it's an
indication regardless of your
chronological age that you are
emotionally mature maybe that's what the
Millennials are but if your economy is
based on consumption to the point that
there is no generosity and materialism
to the point that there is no savings
you have an unstable economy built on
the back of a false set of data meaning
the an unrealistic that cannot
sustainable level of spending and every
time the spending slows down the whole
thing goes into a tailwind and we have
another recession you want to do away
with periodic recessions increase the
savings rate in the generosity rate
because then everything is not so
freakin volatile if companies actually
had retained earnings they wouldn't have
to layoff their people every time there
was a downturn if people actually had
money saved every time they had a
personal downturn they wouldn't be in
trouble
maybe the Millennials are the next great
hope if they've got the highest savings
rate in the last four generations maybe
maybe the economy if the economy the way
you guys in according to the study
according to CNBC if the economy has to
be propped up by excessive materialism
and excessive spending then you don't
have a real economy a steady economy is
the enjoyment of stuff some spending the
enjoyment of earning the enjoyment of
saving and the enjoyment about landish
outrageous generosity Americans spent
seventy billion dollars on our pets last
year
I'm not against frou-frou I love
frou-frou Fifi Rufus the Shih Tzu is
mine but seventy million
seventy billion dollars Wow way to go
Millennials we love you Ramzi we like
you around here